* Lockere Musik *
(Pilot) Willkommen an Bord der
Swissair 111 von New York nach Genf.
Kapitän Urs Zimmermann
und seine Crew
wünschen Ihnen
einen angenehmen Flug.
(Frau) Urs, reinkommen.
Es gibt Abendessen.
(Mann) Es ist unglaublich,
an was für einem seidenen Faden
das Glück hängt.
Steige ich hier ein oder hier?
The emergency exits are ...
- Man konnte sich nicht überlegen,
was da falsch
oder schiefgehen sollte.
Thanks.
Wir hatten alles,
was man sich wünschen kann.
Wir waren rundum glücklich.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Riechst du das?
(Frau) Urs, komm rein.
(Kommentar) Das ist der Tag,
der für die Swissair
als schlimmster Tag
in die Geschichte eingehen wird.
* Ruhige Musik *
(Mann) Urs war ein offener,
liebenswürdiger Mensch.
(Frau)
Urs, das Frühstück ist bereit.
Ihn zeichnete aus, dass er
ein hervorragender Pilot war.
Umso mehr kamen da Fragen auf,
warum jemandem,
der das Handwerk so beherrscht,
so etwas passieren muss.
Es ist so ruhig.
- Nicht mehr lange.
Fünf ...
... vier ...
- ... drei ...
Aber das ist nicht schön.
- ... zwei ...
Lass ihn doch.
- ... eins und ...
Hol es dir doch.
Was ist denn da los?
- Nichts.
Urs, setz dich doch dort hin.
Ich habe nichts gesehen.
Was ist es?
- Ich weiss von nichts.
Sag schon.
- Keine Ahnung.
* Handy *
Daniel?
(Englisch)
Hey.
Ich war Sekretärin und Übersetzerin
bei der amerikanischen Firma
Chris Craft.
Da hat er mich engagiert.
Da funkte es dann nach einer Weile.
Wir lernten uns besser kennen
und zwischen uns
wuchs die gegenseitige Zuneigung,
bis aus der Zuneigung Liebe wurde.
Ja.
Und die ist bis heute geblieben.
Donnerstag?
- Mhm.
Wollte sie nicht
schon am Mittwoch da sein?
Sie will so lange wie möglich
bei ihrem Freund bleiben.
Unser Leben in Genf
was a good life.
Wir führten
ein schönes Leben in Genf.
Wir waren glücklich.
Ich verdiente gut und wir lebten
in einem äusserst angenehmen Klima.
Wir hatten eine
eng verbundene Familie geschaffen.
* Ruhige Klänge *
All die schönen Dinge im Leben,
die wir hatten,
sahen wir als selbstverständlich an.
Wir hatten ein aussergewöhnlich
glückliches Leben.
* Rasante Musik *
* Popmusik *
Wird es bei dir auch so schön?
So würde es bei mir auch aussehen,
wenn ich es selber machte.
Was möchtest du machen? Wegrennen?
Was machst du?
Jeannine.
Was heisst "Ränder"?
* Lachen *
Jeannine war
eine sehr temperamentvolle Frau.
Wir kamen beide aus Adliswil.
Wir kannten uns aus dem Fitnessklub.
Der Zufall wollte,
dass wir uns in New York trafen.
Wir gingen sogar
zusammen zur Pediküre
und ärgerten uns darüber,
dass die so miserabel war.
Wir machten
noch ein paar Einkäufe ...
Wir gingen zusammen einkaufen
und machten alles zusammen.
Bye.
- Bye.
Jeannine lebte für die Fliegerei.
Das war ihr Traumberuf.
(Mann) Es gab ja eine Zeit,
in der sie wegen des Kindes
nicht fliegen konnte.
Sie war schwanger.
Ich entdeckte sie
aber oft im Garten,
wie sie den Fliegern nachschaute.
Irgendwann fand ich:
"Das bringt nichts."
"Du musst wieder gehen,
ich spüre das."
Es war dann fast eine Befreiung ...
... dass sie
das Okay zum Fliegen hatte.
Ich war überzeugt davon,
dass es sie glücklich machte.
Sie war eine Schönheit einer Frau.
Sie konnte für die Swissair
Uniformen modeln.
So wählte man sie auch aus ...
... um bei den Jubiläumsflügen
mitzumachen.
Der Jubiläumsflug des ersten Fluges
nach New York ...
Man bereitete auch eine DC-4 so her
und machte den Flug noch einmal.
Mit den Zwischenlandungen,
die es damals brauchte,
und in den Originaluniformen.
Ich denke, das hat ja fast einen
etwas tragischen Zusammenhang.
So konnte sie den ersten Flug
nach New York machen.
Und ihr letzter Flug
war ja von New York zurück.
(TV)
Die restaurierte DC-4 steht bereit.
Zusammen mit der vierköpfigen Crew
starten rund 30 Personen in Genf
zu diesem modernen Flugabenteuer.
* Pompöse Big-Band-Musik *
Nach über 5'000 km
und insgesamt rund 24 Std. Flugdauer
geht die rüstige alte Tante
so zu Boden,
wie der ganze Flug verlaufen ist:
sanft und weich.
Was muss fliegen
damals Spass gemacht haben.
Was ist?
Stephanie?
Ich habe mir extra freigenommen,
um sie abzuholen.
Du kannst sie am Donnerstag abholen.
- Vielleicht hatte ich Pläne.
Welche?
- Mit Stephanie.
Ich wollte vielleicht
etwas mit ihr unternehmen.
Aber du hattest keine Pläne.
- Aber was, wenn doch?
Hattest du nicht.
* Handy *
Aber leider hasst Gudula es,
Tennis zu spielen.
Well ... Wir können den Deal
auch im Office besprechen.
Stephanie ritt.
Sie ritt mit Leidenschaft.
Sie war die Zweitbeste
der Genfer Juniorreiterinnen.
Ja. Und ... äh ...
Vorher
schwamm sie in einem Schwimmklub -
wie ihr grosser Bruder Olivier.
Das war immer schön.
Die fanden das ganz toll.
(Bader) Mit dem Flugzeug, mit dem
dieses Ereignis dann passierte ...
... flog ich am gleichen Tag
von Zürich nach New York.
Das war ein ganz normaler Flug.
Wir hatten nichts bemerkt.
Auch wenn man sich das
im Nachhinein überlegt ...
Alle sagten, der Flieger
habe sich absolut normal verhalten -
wie bis anhin immer.
(Riesen) Ich war sehr stolz darauf,
für die Swissair zu arbeiten.
Die Anerkennung war auch da.
Die Swissair war d i e Firma.
Sie war weltweit bekannt
und genoss ein grosses Ansehen.
Das war einmalig.
Auch der Geist in dieser Firma -
das sah ich an keinem anderen Ort.
* Energetische Musik *
Sehen wir uns am Montag im Fitness?
- Ja. Guten Flug. - Dir auch.
Bis dann.
- Und wieder Nagelstudio.
Unbedingt.
Wir verabschiedeten uns und sagten,
wir würden uns im Fitness sehen.
Das waren unsere letzten Worte.
Urs.
Hier sind wir. Genf.
Wir brauchen dich.
Die Windverhältnisse sind gut.
- Das ist doch gut.
(Riesen) Es führten immer zwei Flüge
nach New York:
einer über Genf und auch so zurück
und der direkte Flug.
Ich war auf dem Direktflug gebucht.
Jeannine Pompili
war für den Genfer Flug geplant.
Wäre es umgekehrt gewesen,
würde ich vielleicht für Monique
und nicht für Jeannine sprechen.
Manchmal
muss man einfach Glück haben,
damit man
am richtigen Ort einsteigt.
Hi.
(Shaw) Sie hatte ihren Freund,
einen Kanadier.
Er war aber
auch in Genf aufgewachsen
und hatte dort studiert.
Er musste in New York ...
... einen Lehrgang für seine Bank
absolvieren.
Sie wollte ihn besuchen.
Einfach ein paar Tage.
Eine knappe Woche.
Ursprünglich war sie auf
den Rückflug über Zürich gebucht.
Da hatte tatsächlich
einer kurzfristig abgesagt.
Thank you.
Sie konnte dann auf diesen Flug
und war sehr happy.
* Französische Hip-Hop-Musik *
Good evening.
(Bader)
Ich kannte Zimi aus dem Militär.
214 Passagiere plus 15 Crew.
Okay.
Wir machten zusammen Dienst
in der Einsatzzentrale
und verbrachten viele schöne,
lustige Abende zusammen.
Ah, schau mal, Löw. Unten
haben wir einen interessanten Gast.
Hoppla. Picasso.
Zimi und Löw waren in meinen Augen
absolute Spitzenleute.
Thank you.
- Sie hatten nie ein Problem.
Sie waren hervorragende Piloten.
Könnten Sie sich anschnallen?
- Entschuldigung.
(Shaw) Wir erfuhren aus der Zeitung,
dass Tennisspieler Marc Rosset
auf diesen Flug gebucht war ...
... aber es kam ihm
irgendetwas dazwischen.
Wir wissen nicht, was.
Wir nehmen an,
dass das der Platz war,
den Stephanie dann eingenommen hat.
Grüezi.
- Grüezi.
Gestresst?
Ich habe den Flug
im letzten Moment erwischt.
Möchten Sie jemanden informieren?
- Meine Eltern.
Bitte.
Eine Decke für Sie.
(Mann)
Jeannine, Tomatensaft für Sitz 58.
Gut.
(Mit Akzent) "Stephanie, ich warte
schon sehnsüchtig auf dich."
Sorry,
manchmal funktionieren sie nicht.
Um Stephanie zu beschreiben,
gibt es nur ein Wort:
glücklich.
Sie war ein glücklicher Mensch.
- Ja.
Sie war immer guter Laune.
In all unseren Erinnerungen
sehen wir eine lachende Stephanie,
die auch uns zum Lachen brachte.
Darum drehte sich ihr ganzes Leben.
Sie war eine äusserst begabte,
attraktive, junge Frau.
(Pilot) Willkommen an Bord der
Swissair 111 von New York nach Genf.
Kapitän Urs Zimmermann, First
Officer Stephan Löw und seine Crew
wünschen Ihnen
einen angenehmen Flug.
A safety card
is in your seat pocket ...
(Stenz) Wir lernten uns
im Squashcenter kennen.
Ich hatte einen Platz reserviert
und mein Partner kam nicht.
Jeannine wurde an dem Tag
zufälligerweise auch versetzt.
Wir spielten dann zusammen.
Sie war die erste Frau,
die dem Ball jedes Mal nachrannte.
Sie wollte, sie hatte Drive.
Das imponierte mir sehr.
Sie war natürlich auch sonst
eine sehr attraktive Persönlichkeit.
So trafen wir uns nach und nach
immer öfter zum Squash.
Irgendwann hatte ich
so Bauchschmerzen und sagte:
"Entweder kommen wir uns näher
oder hören auf mit Squash."
"Ich halte das nicht mehr aus. Ich
kann nicht mehr essen und schlafen."
Dann liess sie sich erweichen
und rückte ein Stück näher zu mir.
(Bader) Wenn ich die Swissair Ende
der 90er-Jahre beschreiben müsste,
müsste ich
ohne falsche Bescheidenheit sagen,
dass es die leading Airline war.
Andere Airlines wollten sehen,
wie die Swissair das macht.
Flugzeugwartung,
Ausbildung, Operation ...
Das war einzigartig.
(Riesen) Das war d i e Firma
in der Schweiz.
Wir waren wie eine grosse Familie.
Es war für uns selbstverständlich,
in der Not eine extra mile zu gehen.
Natürlich kam es vor,
dass ein Flieger nicht abhob
oder stecken blieb -
aus was für Gründen auch immer.
Dann musste man improvisieren.
Genau diese Situationen
fand ich besonders spannend.
(Stenz)
Wir waren in dieser Zeit getrennt.
Den Kindern zuliebe mietete sie
eine Wohnung in der Nähe.
Schlussendlich machte es das
für mich auch schwieriger,
weil ich immer dachte, dass es
irgendwann wieder klappen würde.
Es ist hart, wenn man alles, was man
sagen wollte, nicht mehr sagen kann.
(Bader)
Ich flog sehr gerne mit der MD-11.
Wir hatten wenige davon.
Es war
ein sehr zuverlässiges Flugzeug.
Es war ja einer der wenigen
dreimotorigen Typen.
Das war immer beruhigend für uns.
Musste man mal
ein Triebwerk ausschalten,
flog man mit zwei
immer noch so komfortabel,
wie heute die meisten fliegen.
Das machte auch Spass.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Gerade.
D1, rotate.
Gear up.
Moncton center,
Swissair 111 heavy, good evening.
Level 330.
Die Swissair war sicher.
Das war nicht nur ein Imagewert.
Durch all die Anstrengungen,
die wir unternommen hatten,
von der Selektion über die Schulung
bis zu laufenden Weiterbildungen,
hatten wir
einen sehr hohen Standard.
* Ruhige Musik *
Voilà.
- Danke.
Zum Wohl.
Der soll ganz gut sein. Ein Typ,
der Bowlingkugeln abschleckt.
"The Big Lebowski".
Lebowski ... Irgendetwas.
Oder vielleicht doch was anderes?
Sie haben 7 1/2 Std. Zeit.
(Bader)
Das In-flight-Entertainment-System,
das in der MD-11 eingebaut wurde,
ist ein Zeichen der Swissair.
Als führende Gesellschaft
kaufte sie nicht einfach ein System.
Es musste das beste sein.
Es war damals das erste System,
das zuliess,
dass jeder Passagier an seinem Platz
individuell einen Film sehen konnte.
Das war ein riesiger Fortschritt.
Das führte zwangsweise
zu gewissen Kinderkrankheiten -
ich nenne es mal so.
Es entwickelte z.B. manchmal
etwas viel Hitze.
Dann musste man es halt ausschalten.
* Düstere Klänge *
Was kostet wohl der Picasso
da unten?
Den hat wahrscheinlich
deine Frau gekauft.
Für deinen 50.
Und dafür hat sie das Haus verkauft?
Der letzte Kurs
mit einer Vier am Rücken.
Ja, hoffentlich.
Wenn deine Frau
das Haus verkauft hat,
hast du einen Picasso,
aber kein Haus.
Was machst du dann?
Wo hängst du das Bild auf?
Zuerst brauche ich wieder ein Haus.
Und dafür müsste ich wohl oder übel
den Picasso verkaufen.
Das löst aber nichts.
Dann hast du eine Wand,
aber kein Bild mehr.
* "Happy Birthday" auf dem Klavier *
* Sie verspielt sich. *
Lara, wenn du es nicht bald kannst,
drehe ich durch.
Wenn Papi kommt, kann ich es.
* Sie spielt "Happy Birthday". *
(Mit hoher Stimme)
Dekorieren wir draussen auch?
Findest du das nicht lustig?
Nein.
* "Happy Birthday" auf dem Klavier *
* Sie verspielt sich. *
* Er schnüffelt intensiv. *
Riechst du das?
Übernimmst du kurz?
Your control.
- My control.
* Düstere Klänge *
(Bader)
Dass man im Cockpit Rauch riecht,
kommt zum Glück praktisch nie vor.
Es kann sein, dass man etwas riecht.
In 99 % oder noch mehr der Fälle
ist es der Ofen der Galley.
Z.B. wird eine Omelette vorbereitet
und man hat etwas zu lange gewartet.
Aber Rauch im Cockpit
kommt praktisch nie vor.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Alles gut bei euch?
- Riechst du was in der Kabine?
Nein, nichts.
Aber bei euch riecht es komisch.
Checkliste: air condition, smoke ...
Erste Schritte:
Econ- und Push-Button off.
(Bader) Wir arbeiten
in der Fliegerei mit Checklisten,
damit die Standardverfahren
von allen gleich gemacht werden.
Das ist die einzige Gewähr,
dass alle Punkte abgehandelt sind.
Es ist sehr wichtig,
dass alle wissen, wovon man spricht.
Man hat Rauch und weiss nicht,
woher er kommt.
Wir haben ja
drei Airconditioning-Systeme.
Eines für jedes Triebwerk.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass in einem dieser Systeme
etwas nicht gut ist,
ist relativ gross.
Ich rieche es immer noch.
Air system manual, Econ P/B on.
Pack 1 off.
* Düstere Klänge *
Pack 1 on. Checklist completed.
Wir müssen runter.
"Pan Pan Pan"
ist ein internationales Zeichen,
bei dem alle Piloten
und Bodenstationen wissen:
"Der hat ein Problem."
Das ist die erste Stufe von "Wir
sind in einer schwierigen Lage".
"Mayday" ist die Stufe ...
... "Jetzt brauche ich Hilfe".
Sie waren gerade
über Boston geflogen.
Wir kennen Boston:
Die Piste ist lang genug
und es hat ein Blindanflugsystem,
das auch in der Nacht
und bei schlechtem Wetter
einen Anflug erlaubt.
Wenn ich landen muss,
würde ich eher nach Boston gehen,
wo Swissair
eine Station und Mechaniker hat.
Wenn man aber die Zeit nicht hat
und man in Halifax ist,
geht man auch dorthin.
Ungeplante Zwischenlandung
in Halifax in rund 20 bis 25 Min.
Kabine vorbereiten, bitte.
* Düstere Klänge *
Cabin crew, prepare for landing.
* Unheilvolle Klänge *
Entschuldigung.
Sie müssen sich anschnallen.
Ein technisches Problem, wir müssen
zwischenlanden. Tut uns leid.
Muss ich mir Sorgen machen? - Nein,
das ist eine Sicherheitsmassnahme.
Aber wir werden Verspätung haben.
Also nichts mit "Dad überraschen".
Er wird es überleben.
Cabin bus off.
(Schmid) Wenn man nicht weiss,
woher es kommt,
deaktiviert man zuerst, was
für den Flug nicht essenziell ist.
Der cabin bus hilft der Kabine.
Die Öfen sind da angehängt.
Man kann keinen Kaffee mehr machen.
Man kann in der Kabine nichts mehr
machen, wenn er deaktiviert ist.
Aber man braucht ihn nicht,
um zu fliegen.
* Leise Gespräche *
Gute Landung.
(Schmid) Wir wissen aus
der Kommunikation mit der Kabine,
dass es in der Kabine hinten
keinen Rauch hatte.
Das war nur im Cockpit.
* Unheilvolle Klänge *
(Bader) Sie flogen Richtung Halifax,
aber sie waren noch zu hoch
und zu schwer.
Bei diesen grossen Fliegern
ist es so, dass das Startgewicht ...
... bis fast 100 t höher ist
als das maximale Landegewicht.
Sie haben dann wirklich
fuel dumping eingeleitet.
Sie haben die Ventile geöffnet,
damit Most abgeht.
Aber sie mussten
auch noch Höhe vernichten.
Sie waren
zu nahe am Flugplatz Halifax.
Ist man zu schnell und zu hoch,
geht es einfach nicht.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
(Schmid) Ich habe mir
den Cockpit-Voice-Recorder angehört.
Es ist unglaublich,
wie ruhig und diszipliniert
im Cockpit gesprochen wurde.
Es gab keinen Versprecher.
Sogar als sie
einen Emergency deklarierten,
was notabene beide Piloten
simultan machten ...
Es musste im Cockpit
etwas passiert sein ...
... dass sofort beiden klar war:
"Jetzt ist es ganz schlimm."
Beide sagten: "Declaring emergency."
(Verzerrt) Roger.
Man muss sich vorstellen,
was in einem Flugzeug passiert,
wenn das gesamte elektrische System
aussteigt.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es
dadurch auch in der Kabine ...
... nicht mehr sehr ruhig war.
Im Cockpit ...
... versuchten sie einfach,
den Flieger ...
... in der Luft zu halten
und ihn zu kontrollieren.
Wir wissen nicht genau,
was am Schluss passiert ist.
* Unheilvolle Klänge *
* Unverständliche Antwort über Funk *
Wir wissen vom Radar her,
wo sie ungefähr durchgeflogen sind.
Aber wir haben keine Kommunikation.
Auch keine Kommunikation
zwischen den Piloten,
weil nichts mehr lief.
Sie flogen noch ungefähr 5 Min.
so weiter.
* Düstere Klänge *
* Knall *
(Mann) Das ist ein Moment,
den ich nie vergessen werde.
Das Telefon klingelte:
Eine Swissair-Maschine
sei vom Radar verschwunden.
Ich sagte meiner Frau, sie werde
mich ein paar Tage nicht sehen,
und fuhr Richtung Flughafen.
Ich kam ins Büro -
ich war der Erste und der Einzige.
Alle Telefone klingelten. Alle.
Das ganze Büro
klingelte und klingelte.
Man wusste noch nicht,
was genau passiert war.
Wir wussten auch lange nicht,
ob es New York - Zürich
oder New York - Genf war.
Wir hatten ja im Halifax-Gebiet
gleichzeitig vier Flugzeuge
in der Luft.
Es ist der SR111. Genf.
* Düstere Klänge *
(Riesen)
Ich konnte es nicht glauben.
Ich konnte es einfach nicht glauben.
Ich glaube, das ist so, dass man ...
So aus dem Leben
rausgerissen zu werden ...
Ich kannte ja
praktisch alle an Bord.
* Traurige Klänge *
* Lockere Musik aus dem Radio *
6 Uhr,
Schweizer Radio DRS "Morgenjournal".
* Jingle *
Am Mikrofon ist Daniel Eisner.
Die Swissair-Maschine
des Fluges New York - Genf
ist an der Ostküste Kanadas
abgestürzt.
Dies ist das Hauptthema der Sendung.
Vor wenigen Stunden
ist das Swissair-Flugzeug
des Kurses New York - Genf
über dem Osten Kanadas abgestürzt.
Die Maschine des Typs MD-11 war am
Abend Ortszeit in New York gestartet
und stürzte wenig später
an der Küste von Neuschottland,
unweit der Hauptstadt Halifax, ab.
Von der Swissair war bis jetzt ...
Mami.
- Was ist los?
Hey.
* Man hört Stimmen aus dem Radio. *
Tabea?
Tabea, was ist los?
Papi ist abgestürzt.
(Radio) Das Flugzeug verschwand
in einer Höhe von ungefähr 350 m
um 22.30 Uhr Ortszeit.
(Riesen)
Man musste Passagiere bedienen ...
... und so tun,
als wäre nichts passiert.
Wir wollten ja,
dass die Passagiere aussteigen,
ohne etwas zu wissen.
Sie sollten es
erst draussen erfahren.
Ich war froh,
dass es ein Nachtflug war.
Die meisten Passagiere schliefen.
Und ...
... auf dem Flug,
also in dieser Zeit,
wurden Telefone
in der Kabine eingebaut.
Das wurde zu einem Gag,
dass man aus 10'000 m Höhe
nach Hause anrufen konnte.
Und ...
Es gab ein paar in der Economy,
die in dieser Zeit telefonierten.
Möchten Sie etwas Wasser?
Mit oder ohne? - Ja, ohne.
Die zwei erfuhren,
dass der 111er abgestürzt war.
* Intensives Flüstern *
(Flight Attendant)
Möchten Sie nach hinten kommen?
Der Maître de Cabine
musste die zwei in die Küche nehmen
und sie unter Kontrolle bringen.
Wir hatten einen vollen Flieger
mit 220 Passagieren.
Panik an Bord
wäre eine Katastrophe gewesen.
Möchten Sie Wasser? Mit oder ohne?
- Gerne ohne.
Ich sollte sie am nächsten Morgen
am Genfer Flughafen abholen.
Wir freuten uns wahnsinnig
auf ihre Heimkehr.
Wir hatten nicht mehr direkt
mit ihr gesprochen.
Doch dann, frühmorgens, erhielt
Gudula einen Anruf aus New York.
From ...
- ... her boyfriend.
Von ihrem Freund.
- Ja.
Und er fragte ...
... ob wir etwas von Stephanie
gehört hätten.
Da sagte ich: "Nein."
Sie war ja gar nicht auf dem Flug.
Er sagte: "Dann machen Sie mal
den Fernseher an."
Da sah man ... Das war schlimm.
Das war ganz schlimm.
(TV)
Bilder des kanadischen Fernsehens.
Dutzende Schiffe der
kanadischen Marine sind unterwegs.
Sie werden von unzähligen
Fischerbooten unterstützt.
Mit Leuchtkörpern
wird die Szenerie erhellt.
Augenzeugen berichten von
Flugzeugstücken und Leichenteilen,
die im Meer schwimmen.
Das Meer - ein riesiges Trümmerfeld.
Ian!
Hören Sie ...
Sie war auf dem Flug nach Zürich.
Oder nach Genf.
Ja.
Ja?
Ja, Stephanie Shaw.
Mhm.
Nein.
Forget it. Forget them.
They don't have it.
"Geduld", sagt sie. Patience.
- Fucking ... Still there? Hello?
(Shaw) Die wussten natürlich,
dass sie dabei war.
Aber sie wollten noch nichts sagen,
weil sie nicht wussten ...
... was sie
den Familien sagen sollten.
(TV) Sie sind gekommen,
um ihre Angehörigen abzuholen.
Aber SR111 wird nicht landen.
Zuerst hiess es bloss "retardé",
also "verspätet".
Dann der Schock:
Flug SR111 abgestürzt.
Immer wieder der Blick auf
den Monitor - eine hilflose Geste.
Informationen gibt es wenige -
und wenn, dann nur schlechte.
Kaum waren wir in Genf gelandet ...
... nahmen uns der Flughafendirektor
und der Regierungspräsident von Genf
in Empfang und sagten ...
... wir müssten sofort
zum Medienzentrum.
Da traf mich fast der Schlag.
Da standen 50 bis 60 Medienleute
aus der ganzen Welt.
Bis man wusste, was passiert war,
ging es sehr, sehr lange.
Wir hatten die Devise,
immer wieder zu informieren,
aber nur Facts.
Ich habe es am Radio gehört.
Ich kann nur hoffen,
dass mein Sohn nicht an Bord war.
Bis jetzt weiss ich nichts.
Ich warte.
(Shaw) Das waren dramatische
Stunden, die wir warten mussten.
Man wusste bestimmt schon beim Ein-
checken, wer auf welchem Flug war.
Ne?
Man sagte uns: "Warten Sie ab ...
... bis der Flieger
in Zürich gelandet ist,
dann sagen wir Ihnen Bescheid."
(TV) 8.30 Uhr in der Ankunftshalle
des Flughafens Kloten, Terminal A.
Viele Angehörige von Passagieren
des Direktflugs nach Zürich
möchten wissen, ob ihre Leute nicht
doch in der Unglücksmaschine waren.
Aber der Informationsdienst
kann nicht weiterhelfen.
Ein Freund wollte wissen,
wann meine Tochter ankomme.
Ich sagte: "Um 10.15 Uhr."
Er meinte, es sei einer abgestürzt,
also musste ich hierherkommen.
* Schwermütige Klänge *
(Riesen) Wie nahe das Leben
und der Tod sich sind,
wurde mir damals
zum ersten Mal richtig bewusst.
Das sind Sekundenbruchteile,
die entscheiden.
Ich schrammte haarscharf
daran vorbei.
Wir standen in New York
nebeneinander.
Die Flieger waren nebeneinander.
Wir sahen sie noch,
weil wir nachher kamen.
Sie rollten gerade weg.
Ich hätte locker
auf dem Flug sein könne.
Es hätte
auch unser Flieger sein können.
(TV) Meine Schwester
müsste eigentlich hier sein,
aber ich bin nicht sicher,
dass sie in letzter Minute
umbuchen musste.
So wie Julie Gerster
ging es fast allen.
Umso grösser die Erleichterung, als
ihre Schwester endlich auftauchte.
Sie erfuhr erst hier,
was mit der anderen Swissair-Maschine
passiert war.
Allen
fiel ein riesiger Stein vom Herzen.
Auch den Krähenbühls aus Herisau,
die fast auf den Unglücksflieger
gebucht wurden.
Ein Flug vor uns stürzte ab.
Die MD-11.
Dieselbe wie unsere.
- Sie hoben 20 Min. vor uns ab.
Ich sprach mit ein paar Passagieren
am Flughafen.
"Guten Flug" - und dann ... ja ...
Sie hatten Kontakt mit den Leuten?
Die Flieger
standen nebeneinander.
Unser Flieger in Gate 5,
ihrer in Gate 6.
20 Min. vor uns. Der muss rauf
und direkt runter sein.
Das Furchtbarste ...
... für ein Unternehmen
wie das unsere ...
... für Führungsverantwortliche
in unserem Unternehmen ...
... ist diese Nacht geschehen.
(TV) Noch in der Nacht
wurden erste Leichen geborgen.
Die sterblichen Überreste
der Passagiere
wurden in eine provisorische
Aufbahrungshalle gebracht.
Dort sollen sie identifiziert werden.
Die Suche dauert an.
(Frau) Das Telefon klingelte
und mein Vorgesetzter war dran.
Er erzählte mir ganz ruhig ...
... dass in der Nacht
ein Flugzeug abgestürzt war.
Das hatte so etwas Surreales.
"Die Swissair ist so sicher und
qualitäts- und sicherheitsbewusst -
das kann doch nicht sein."
Wir führten
ein sehr ruhiges Gespräch zusammen.
Er sagte mir,
ich sei auf dem ersten Flugzeug.
Man schicke mich mit einer Gruppe
von Leuten, von Journalisten rüber.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Wer die Gegend kennt, weiss,
dass das so eine schöne Gegend ist.
Das hat die Dramatik noch erhöht.
Die Gegend ist so dramatisch schön.
Wir mussten organisieren,
dass man so nahe wie möglich
an die Stelle rankommen konnte -
dorthin,
wo das Flugzeug ins Meer stürzte.
Wir wussten nicht,
was wir dort antreffen würden.
Schaukeln
irgendwelche Flugzeugteile rum?
Was muss man dort erwarten?
* Melancholische Klänge *
(Schmid) Nach der Landung gingen wir
auf die Shearwater Air Force Base.
Dort fand auch
die ganze Untersuchung statt.
Wir machten in einer Hercules
einen Search-and-Rescue-Flight,
also einen Flug,
auf dem man Überlebende suchte.
Die hatte einen Glasboden.
Man flog einfach tief.
Wir sahen Petrollachen, einzelne
Sitzkissen und sonst nichts.
Ian ...
* Unheilvolle Klänge *
Ich wusste es bereits.
Ich hatte diese Vorahnung,
dass sie tot war.
Dann kamen ein Polizist und eine
Vertreterin der Swissair zu uns
und überbrachten uns
die Nachricht von ihrem Tod.
Das war der Anfang vom Ende.
* Unheilvolle Klänge *
* Düstere Klänge *
(Stenz) Weil wir getrennt waren,
waren meine Daten
bzw. meine Telefonnummer ...
... anscheinend
nicht sofort auffindbar.
Ja, dann ging ich
so schnell wie möglich nach Hause -
in der Hoffnung, dass ich
irgendwelche Informationen kriege.
Als ich nach Hause kam,
standen bereits Freunde von uns
vor der Türe,
auch zwei Fliegende,
um mich zu empfangen,
um mich in dieser Situation
nicht allein zu lassen.
Es war sehr hart, als die Kinder
von der Schule nach Hause kamen
und ich es ihnen sagen musste.
Das war der schlimmste Moment ...
... in der ganzen Geschichte.
Das ist hart.
* Melancholische Klänge *
So etwas zu erfahren,
ist ein Trauma.
Der Effekt war, dass
nichts anderes mehr wichtig war.
Ich vergass die Namen
meiner Nachbarn,
ich erkannte die Leute
auf der Strasse nicht mehr ...
Ja, es war erstaunlich. Vorher ...
... funktionierte ich gut,
aber in dem Moment ging nichts mehr.
Mami?
Mami.
(TV) Seit über 30 Std.
sind die Retter
vor der Küste von Halifax im Einsatz,
fischen Bruchstücke
des schlimmsten Unglücks in der
Geschichte der Swissair aus dem Meer:
Taschen des Personals ...
- (Frau) Get the small stuff.
... Teile des Flugzeugs ...
Do whatever you can.
... Habseligkeiten der Passagiere.
It's people.
Ein Fund
war besonders herzzerreissend:
ein Liebesbrief, den jemand
während des Flugs schrieb.
Wir fanden ihn im Wasser und
steckten ihn in eine Plastikhülle.
Die Küstenwache
wird ihn der Familie übergeben.
Ich erhielt viele Anrufe ...
... von Freunden und Bekannten.
Ich war dann
natürlich völlig überdreht.
Ich sollte schlafen ...
Ich wusste aber,
dass ich das ohne Hilfe nicht kann.
Ich ging dann in die Apotheke
und erklärte mein Problem.
Der Apotheker meinte nur,
ich solle eine Tablette nehmen ...
... und unbedingt Hilfe
in Anspruch nehmen.
Ich müsse ihm versprechen,
dass ich wirklich zum Arzt gehe.
(TV) Heute Morgen, nach 11 Uhr:
Die Konzernspitze der Swissair
steht vor einem schwierigen Auftritt.
Ich möchte mein Beileid
an alle Betroffenen aussprechen -
seien das Angehörige von Passa-
gieren oder Besatzungsmitgliedern.
Wir alle sind schockiert.
(TV) Es ist das schlimmste Desaster
in der Schweizer Luftfahrtgeschichte.
Die ganze Schweiz trauert mit.
Die Flaggen stehen auf halbmast.
Im Namen des Bundesrates
spreche ich den Angehörigen der
Opfer unser tiefstes Beileid aus.
Wir werden morgen um 10 Uhr ...
... einen Flug für Angehörige
nach Halifax fliegen.
(TV) Um 10.30 Uhr
begann für 75 Geschwister, Eltern,
Ehepartner und Freunde der Opfer
die schwerste Reise ihres Lebens:
die Reise nach Kanada
an den Unglücksort.
Alle Angehörigen
werden während der ganzen Zeit
von einer Betreuerin
oder einem Betreuer begleitet.
Es war noch nicht ganz 13 Uhr,
als der Airbus 310
Richtung Halifax abhob.
Der Kontrollturm verabschiedete sich:
"Einen guten Tag noch, Swissair,
und auf Wiedersehen."
Auch ich
nahm diesen Flug nach Halifax,
während Gudula zu Hause blieb.
In Kanada wurden wir warm empfangen.
Die Menschen dort haben sich
liebevoll um uns gekümmert.
Ihre eigene Erschütterung
löste in mir
eine Art Zugehörigkeitsgefühl aus.
Sie waren alle so nett zu mir.
Das war das wichtigste Element
während der zwei Tage in Halifax.
(TV) Der Leuchtturm von Peggy's Cove
heute früh.
Für die Angehörigen der Opfer wurde
er zum Sinnbild der Katastrophe.
Sie tragen persönliche Erinnerungen
mit sich.
Im Laufe des Tages -
die Sonne hat den Nebel verdrängt -
kommen
mehr als 300 Frauen und Männer.
Sie haben unterwegs Blumen gepflückt,
halten sich gegenseitig fest,
kauern auf dem kargen Boden oder
schauen einfach aufs Meer hinaus.
Wir können auf den Friedhof,
wenn wir jemanden verlieren.
Wir können Blumen hinlegen
und haben viele Zeremonien.
Wenn so ein dramatisches Ereignis
passiert ...
Sie können nur in Peggy's Cove
hinstehen und aufs Meer schauen.
Aber das muss möglich sein.
Man schafft Nähe zu einem Ort ...
... an dem jemand, der einem
nahesteht, das Leben verloren hat.
* Düstere Klänge *
(Brandes) Man muss sich vorstellen,
dass diese Menschen
etwas vom Liebsten verloren haben.
Die einen sind still,
die anderen ...
... versuchen irgendwie ...
... so zu tun,
als wäre alles unter Kontrolle.
Wir erlebten wirklich
sehr verschiedene Situationen.
Wir erlebten, wie z.B. ...
... Menschen aus
einem anderen Kulturkreis sagten ...
... sie wollten eine Aufnahme davon
sehen, wie ihr Familienmitglied ...
... in das Flugzeug stieg.
Anders
akzeptierten sie den Tod nicht.
Oder wir hatten einen Scheich,
der sagte,
sie würden nicht gehen, bevor sie
seinen Körper nicht gefunden hätten,
damit sie den Körper
ehren und würdigen
und dann
ehrenvoll beisetzen konnten.
* Düstere Klänge *
Ursprünglich nahm man an,
man könne die Verstorbenen
in offenen Särgen präsentieren,
damit die Angehörigen sie
visuell identifizieren können.
Man merkte dann schnell,
dass das nicht geht.
Man fand eine einzige Person
als ganzen Körper,
den man auch so erkennen konnte.
Alles andere
war sehr stark zerstört.
Es gab eine Halle in diesem Hotel,
in der wir uns alle versammelten.
Es hatte sogar eine Bühne.
Der Chefforensiker
musste ihnen diese schwierige ...
... Mitteilung machen.
* Traditioneller Gesang
der First Nations *
(TV) Mit diesem Gesang schicken
die Indianer von Neuschottland
ihre Verstorbenen
in die nächste Welt.
Wasser ist für sie heilig,
ein guter Ort.
Der Gedenkgottesdienst für die Opfer
der verunglückten Swissair-Maschine
und gleichzeitig Danksagung an alle,
die bei ihrer Bergung mithelfen.
Angereist sind auch
Bundespräsident Flavio Cotti
und Kanadas Ministerpräsident
Jean Chrétien.
"Den Familien der Opfer
kann ich nur sagen,
dass sie im Geiste immer bei uns sind
und wir sie nie vergessen werden",
sagt Priester Richard Walsh.
Vom kanadischen Volk
ein Blumenkranz aufs Meer
und ein letzter Kanonensalut.
Der Empfang in Halifax
bleibt mir immer noch im Kopf.
Ich war ja allein.
Da standen - in militärischen Ehren
- Leute in Uniform ...
... und empfangen mich
und salutieren.
Das war so ein ...
... wahnsinnig ergreifender Moment.
(TV) Tiefe Betroffenheit,
als die Namen
der 229 Passagiere verlesen werden.
Anne Sophie Hoel.
François Hoel.
Marie-Françoise Hoel.
Olivia Hoel.
Paul Edouard Hoel.
* Traurige Musik *
(Schmid) Am siebten Tag ging ich
zum ersten Mal nach Peggy's Cove.
Ich wollte sehen,
wohin alle pilgerten.
Ich ging dorthin ...
... setzte mich auf die Steine ...
... und brach zusammen.
Da brach es über mich hinein.
Ich weinte rund eine halbe Stunde.
Dann ging ich wieder zurück.
* Düstere Klänge *
(TV) Seit sieben Wochen
machen sich jeden Tag Hunderte
von Helfern per Boot auf den Weg
zur Absturzstelle
vor dem Fischerdorf Peggy's Cove.
Tonnen trauriger Fracht werden jeden
Abend bei Halifax an Land gebracht.
Spezialisten aus dem ganzen Land
werden die menschlichen Überreste
in quälender Kleinarbeit
untersuchen und katalogisieren.
(Markwalder)
Viele Leute arbeiteten mit.
Rund 500 Armeeangehörige,
54 Zahnärzte und Zahnarzthelfer
der kanadischen Armee.
Ungefähr 50 Polizeibeamte.
Das war ein riesiger Aufwand,
aber alles war perfekt organisiert.
(TV) Die Leichenteile
werden zu einem Luftwaffenstützpunkt
bei Halifax gebracht.
Nach der Inspektion durch
Gerichtsmediziner in einem Hangar,
werden die menschlichen Überreste
in riesigen Kühlcontainern
tiefgefroren.
Das Ziel war,
sämtliche Opfer zu identifizieren.
Das erreichte man.
Man versuchte, die Körper
nach den klassischen und schnellsten
Methoden zu identifizieren.
Das ist einerseits
der Fingerabdruck.
Das andere sehr effiziente Mittel
war
die zahnärztliche Identifikation.
Und schlussendlich
die DNA-Untersuchung.
* Schritte *
Isst du?
* Handy *
Sie wollen wissen,
wann du zurückkommst.
Okay.
Yeah.
(Shaw) Nach dem Unfall
lagen erst mal die Nerven blank.
Man wird unerträglich
für den Partner.
Man fand alles schrecklich,
was der andere machte.
Gegenseitig.
Es war so, dass das Unheil
plötzlich kam - über Nacht.
Sprichwörtlich.
Und ... das hat ...
... unsere ganze Lebensbasis
auf den Kopf gestellt.
Sie ist auch meine Tochter.
Tu peux venir, Stephanie.
- We're all here.
Salut.
- She doesn't look as if she is ...
... 15. She is 16.
- Oh.
# Happy birthday to you.
# Happy birthday, dear Stephanie.
(Aus dem Fernseher)
# Happy birthday to you.
* Stimmen *
Discman,
Discman, Discman, Discman ...
Thanks.
Bye, dad.
- Bye-bye.
Bye.
- Bye.
(Shaw) Wir müssen uns
immer bewusst sein ...
... dass unser Leben
aus der Vergangenheit ...
... der Gegenwart und der Zukunft
besteht.
Bei Stephanie ist alles
in einer Schachtel verstaut,
die nur die Vergangenheit enthält.
Es gibt keine Gegenwart
und keine Zukunft.
Beides existiert nicht.
Ich habe kürzlich gehört, dass
der Gemahl der britischen Königin,
der Duke of Edinburgh,
einmal gesagt hat:
"Wenn im Leben
etwas ganz Schlimmes passiert,
muss man anhalten,
sich das Geschehene vor Augen halten
und sich eingestehen,
dass es wirklich passiert ist."
"Nur so kann man damit weiterleben."
Tut man das nicht, versinkt man.
Man muss damit weiterleben
und etwas Positives daraus machen.
Lecker. Danke, Mami.
Bitte.
Hast du das Paket gesehen?
Von der Swissair.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Schön.
Die Uniformen?
- Nein, wenn du lächelst.
Hm.
Die Frage nach dem Grund für den
Absturz beschäftigte mich lange.
Man wusste es ja lange nicht.
Also ... Man hatte eine Ahnung.
Soweit ich mich erinnern kann,
war das
der bestuntersuchte Flugzeugunfall.
Man scheute wirklich keine Kosten.
Man wollte wirklich wissen,
was passiert war.
(TV) Sie suchen und sammeln
die Trümmer einer MD-11,
in denen verborgene Spuren
erzählen können,
warum die Maschine abgestürzt ist.
Die meisten dieser Trümmerteile
befinden sich auf dem Meeresgrund,
rund 60 m unter der Oberfläche.
In den ersten Tagen
werden hauptsächlich Taucher
für die Bergung eingesetzt.
Ein schwieriger Job.
Stück für Stück
wird einzeln eingesammelt,
denn untersucht werden kann nur,
was wieder ans Tageslicht gelangt.
Man setzt ein Wrack nach
einem Unfall nicht oft zusammen.
Man macht es dann,
wenn die Rekonstruktion des Wracks
etwas zeigt,
was man sonst nicht rausfinden kann.
In diesem Fall war es ja so,
dass das Flugzeug innen brannte.
Als es ins Wasser fiel,
wurde es auf einen Schlag gelöscht.
So gab es eine Art Endzustand.
Dieser sagt etwas darüber aus,
wie sich das Feuer entwickelt hat -
wenn man das entsprechend
zurückrechnen kann.
Manchmal arbeitest du hier zwei,
drei Tage, ohne dass etwas passiert.
Das kann schon frustrierend sein.
Aber an anderen Tagen -
vielleicht liegt es an den Sternen -
passen die Teile
sehr schön zusammen.
Hm, das ist wieder eine Möglichkeit.
Das sieht so aus,
als wäre es mal zusammen gewesen.
Sehen Sie? Das Band hier
stimmt mehr oder weniger überein.
Ein kleines Stück fehlt,
aber es ist möglich,
dass das zusammenpasst.
Ich würde sagen, dass es passt.
Man muss sehen,
dass 229 Menschen ums Leben kamen.
Das löste sehr viel Leid aus.
Ich würde sagen, wenn man nur einen
solchen Unfall verhindern kann,
rechtfertigt sich dieser Aufwand
auf jeden Fall.
Da hattest du das Café
schon entdeckt.
Das Restaurant,
das du dann gekauft hast.
Das war auf meiner zweiten Reise.
Auch die war von Swissair
organisiert worden.
Da war dieses Gasthaus.
Ich sah, dass es zum Verkauf stand.
Während ich dort war,
machte ich ein Kaufangebot.
No.
Okay. Du musst dir vorstellen:
Hier sitzen die Alten.
Oh.
Hier kann das Menü ...
Schmaler, schmaler.
Da.
Wir machen das Menü hier:
"Frische Fische".
Oh my God, no, we can ...
The old guys ...
Die alten Leute hier.
And we can here auch ... Look ...
Ich ... Ich finde es gut,
dass du etwas Neues probierst.
(Shaw) Ich war einfach froh,
dass er sich da wiedergefunden hat.
Für mich war Nordamerika
überhaupt keine Option.
Das ist es auch heute noch nicht.
Ich bin Europäerin
mit Leib und Seele.
Nordamerika ist nicht meine Welt.
Das ist wirklich eine andere Kultur.
Und dann
in so einem gottverlassenen Dorf ...
... am Rande von Kanada ...
Was sollte ich da machen?
Für Gudula
wäre das kein Leben gewesen.
Sie war unglaublich tolerant
und liess mich gehen.
Sie gönnte mir die Freiheit,
dorthin zu gehen.
* Schwermütige Klänge *
(TV) Anfang Oktober 2001.
Die Öffentlichkeit
will eine Antwort auf die Frage
nach dem Ausgangspunkt des Feuers.
24 mögliche Varianten
des Katastrophenverlaufs
stehen zur Diskussion.
Aufgrund
der Auslegeordnung der Kabelbündel
können die Drähte ziemlich genau
dort positioniert werden,
wo sie sich im Flugzeug
befunden hatten.
Jetzt ist die Stelle
einwandfrei bestimmt,
wo der entscheidende Funke
den Brand ausgelöst haben muss.
Das passt.
Im Modell finden Jim und Don
die Stelle schnell.
Da muss es sein:
innerhalb des Cockpits,
gleich vor der Rückwand.
Dieselbe Stelle
im Cockpit einer MD-11.
Verborgen hinter dem Paneel
mit den Sicherungen,
hinter Drähten,
Kabeln und Befestigungsteilen
fügen sich die Puzzleteile zusammen.
An dieser uneinsehbaren Stelle
hat der Kurzschluss
mit grosser Wahrscheinlichkeit
die Isolationsmatten entzündet.
(Knecht) Vor dem Unfall
war man sich zu wenig bewusst,
dass die Isolationsmatten zwar mit
offenen Flammen getestet wurden ...
Das Material hatte die Eigenschaft,
sich von der Flamme
sozusagen zurückzuziehen.
Dadurch konnte es
nicht richtig zu brennen beginnen.
Man entdeckte
erst im Rahmen der Untersuchung,
dass ein Funke nicht zu diesem
Zurückweichen des Materials führte.
Eine offene Flamme schon,
ein Funke nicht.
Ein Funke reichte aus,
um nicht mehr so feuerresistentes
Material zu entfachen.
(TV) Die alten Swissair-Matten, die
den bisherigen Test bestanden hatten,
werden im Labor
dem neuen Verfahren unterzogen.
3 Sek. lang hätte das Feuer brennen
dürfen und nicht weiter als 5 cm.
Die Matte brannte 7 Min.
nach der Entzündung immer noch.
Die Unfalluntersucher
gehen davon aus,
dass das Bordunterhaltungssystem
mit grosser Wahrscheinlichkeit
in die Auslösung des Feuers
involviert war.
Damals - das ist vielleicht
auch noch anders als heute -
konsumierten solche Systeme,
allein wegen der Bildschirme,
sehr viel mehr Leistung.
Es lief sicher beim Einbau
etwas nicht optimal,
weswegen es
zum Brandausbruch kommen konnte.
Wir aus der Operation und auch
die Techniker aus ihrer Sicht ...
... sagten, das System
sei noch nicht optimal ausgereift.
Wir stellten entsprechende Anträge,
das vor dem Einbau
noch weiterzuentwickeln.
Die oberste Führung
entschied dann ...
... unter Druck des Marketings,
dass das System eingebaut wird.
In einer sehr grossen Übung
wurde das dann eingebaut.
Wir mussten Fremde reinbringen,
damit das gemacht werden konnte.
Ich denke, das war suboptimal.
(Shaw) Ich ging nicht dorthin,
um möglichst nahe bei Stephanie
zu sein.
Ich ging dorthin, weil die Umstände
dieses Fischerdorf
und dieses Gasthaus mit seinem Laden
auf meinen Weg gelegt hatten.
Es gab mir die Möglichkeit,
mich von Genf abzuwenden
und von all den Dingen, die in
meinen Augen mein Leben ausmachten.
So konnte ich
mit den wenigen Bruchstücken,
die mir geblieben waren,
eine neue Existenz aufbauen,
in der ich einen Beitrag zum Leben
leisten konnte.
Hi there.
(Shaw) Er hat sich einen Namen
als vorzüglicher Hummerort gemacht,
wo man gut Hummer essen konnte.
Und?
Hast du genügend Hummer bekommen?
Okay.
Ja, aber die Fallen waren alle leer.
(Shaw) Über all die Jahre -
ich glaube, es waren acht -
hatten wir immer
telefonischen Kontakt.
Ich spürte, dass ich dabei war.
Wir ...
... lernten ...
... miteinander zu leben,
ohne zusammen zu sein.
Auch wenn wir auf zwei verschiedenen
Kontinenten lebten,
blieb während dieser ganze Zeit
das gegenseitige Verständnis.
Ja.
Bye.
- Bye.
Bye-bye.
Ich konnte sie nicht verändern.
Sie hatte
ihre eigene Persönlichkeit
und z.T.
ganz andere Meinungen als ich.
Und ich hatte meine Persönlichkeit,
mit z.T.
ganz anderen Meinungen als sie.
Ich glaube, das ist heute noch so.
- Yeah.
Absolutely.
Wir sind eigentlich
doch recht glücklich,
muss ich sagen.
Ja.
(Riesen)
Ich flog danach nie mehr so locker.
Start und Landung wurden für mich
immer zu einem Spannungsmoment.
So verlor ich meine Sorglosigkeit
für die Fliegerei.
(Stenz)
Ich staune immer noch darüber,
wie stark mich das mitnimmt,
wenn ich darüber sprechen muss.
Es war natürlich trotz der ...
... Auseinandersetzungen
und dem Auseinanderleben
eine tiefe Liebe da.
Die geht nicht weg.
Wenn man philosophisch
darüber sprechen möchte,
besteht ja doch die Hoffnung,
dass wir uns
vielleicht wieder irgendwo treffen,
wenn ich dann mal abdanke.
Man klammert sich
an solche Gedanken.
# Angels fell right out of the sky.
# There was no time to say goodbye.
# Broken wings wrote on the blue.
# Broken hearts and broken parts -
I pray one day I'll be a whole.
# Close my heart, save my soul.
# In the night, out of the light.
# In the darkness at night.
# In the night, in the dark.
# Fallen angels - into the light.
# In search of what was left,
it ripped a hole in my chest.
# Torn apart, torn to pieces.
Denkst du, das ist Mami?
- Vielleicht.
# Searching words of Jesus
while digging my own grave.
# My momma told me once:
"Just be brave."
# In the night, out of the light.
# In the darkness at night.
# In the night, in the dark.
# Fallen angels - into the light.
# In the night.
# In the dark.
# Fallen angels - into the light.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022